a lot of people are accepting situations
that are lesser than what you really
want just because it's something well
guess what something isn't always better
than nothing okay Suddenly Single after
a marriage breakdown and the male
friends around me are behaving so
weirdly
I've not got many straight male friends
because my ex-husband didn't like it he
left me in a terrible way under terrible
circumstances with a newborn baby so
understandably I'm pretty traumatized
however I'm fighting that the straight
male friends I do have are all shooting
their bloody shot and trying to get me
in a bit I'm not a supermodel or
anything just an average looking 31 year
old
that's uh that's normally enough you
don't have to be a supermodel yeah you
have to be cute enough yeah
I've had one friend send me explicit
messages about a dream he had about me
one called me in the middle of the night
started asking for sexy picks and
another straight up hitting on me on a
daily basis I'm at the most vulnerable
and traumatized and I feel like they're
asked they're trying to take advantage
of me do most men do most men genuinely
suck am I missing something
um
I don't think that most men suck
well first and foremost there's always
going to be someone that's going to be
as horny as real ugly
second thing is
I don't know I don't know the situation
you have with these people and
everything and stuff but what I've
noticed in the world is that there's a
lot of people that use the word friends
too Loosely you got to make the
difference between a colleague an
acquaintance someone you just met once
and a friend or a predator and waiting
yes yes
yes a friend is a strong ass word but
people use it very Loosely just like the
word love
same way that I the same way that I said
that uh men mostly have
more respect for the word love than
women because women use it more Loosely
I love this I love this I love that oh
same thing with friends and that's for
everybody though the friend thing y'all
use loose loose
you meet for a couple of beers with a
couple of people and suddenly you're
friends and I'm like nah that's not the
definition of friends oh my God I can't
believe that that person why why would
you can't why wouldn't you believe that
you just you just meet to go drinks
that's not friends
that's bar acquaintances maybe I'm too
particular on the words and stuff like
that but what I noticed is that people
really use the word friends too Loosely
for everything and anyone and everyone
that's a friend no that's a word
colleague you only see them in the
context of work
colleague it's not a friend
anyways
I don't know I think like it's kind of
beating a dead horse a bit but just
I think a lot of women overestimate how
friendly
some of their male counterparts are in
their lives and how platonic it actually
is not realizing something we're just
waiting for an opportunity
they can be cordial they can be fine and
then once you're single they make they
shoot their shot now is that wrong
I don't know
maybe you would date them if you were
single that happens all the time how
many women leave a relationship and
start dating their so-called friend or
how many people say I want a friendship
first and then start dating the person
that happens all the time so like it's
hard for me to say I think it's a bit
deceptive when you say like there's no
interest whatsoever there never will be
and then you shoot your shot after the
fact right like that's probably the
deceptive part but I mean I don't even
know how wrong this kind of behavior
really is I would just say that maybe
that's the reason why your ex-husband
had an issue with some of these
so-called male friends that you had I
think it's just being mindful to be
really honest with yourself to really
actually like look at the men in your
lives and really ask yourself like why
are they actually in my life are they
just waiting you know and for some
people they don't mind being there why
because they're not sitting by the phone
the whole time they're just like oh they
say hi two three times a year and
they're cordial oh you're single I'm
single why do we go out for drinks and
then you guys go out for drinks you
start dating how many women come out of
a divorce and want somebody they can be
intimate with why because their divorce
had a lot of intimacy issues it happens
all the time so while it might be weird
in this situation there's plenty other
breakups where
people monkey Branch they go from one
dude to the next or one woman to the
next they've already lined it up well
who is that person a friend
the truth is human relationships are
missing
categories aren't separate Believe It or
Not oftentimes they overlap they're more
like Venn diagrams right friends go from
friends to friends with benefits or
friends go from French to nope I think
or friends go from France to marriage
like it happens all the time people are
friends for eight nine years and all of
a sudden they're dating long term that's
beautiful that's cute well that same
dude could be the one that you rejected
like why would he try to make a move on
me it's like I don't like what y'all
want me to tell you you're around people
enough romantic feelings can sometimes
develop between the opposite sex in you
it's like I don't know
so how do I feel about this one not
surprised it's probably the best way I
could put it no because you know what it
is man you know what I say
I sold it a crime can become a dick to
ride on there you go so that's my
thoughts on this whole thing envious no
let us know what you got there okay cool
guy I was sleeping with blocked me after
I asked if we will ever be more it's
about to get pity
I've been F buddies with this guy for
eight years boom all we ever do is drive
to him have sex or give him all I ever
do
yeah get it in or or give a BJ then
leave immediately
he dated other people but never me oh
honey
what was that it's like you you went oh
honey it's like when someone got cancer
and you know they got cancer but they
don't know they got cancer yeah and you
gotta break the news that was my girl to
me won't talk about my dad oh okay
because I went to my girls like what's
wrong to you so what's wrong with your
dad I was like
oh no that's cool you know you just have
to
get something in his head removed and
then uh
uh they're gonna do some chemo and then
they're gonna do uh some radio so yeah
and then she looked at me and she was
like
that's cancer and I was like
oh you didn't know
I it like it didn't I didn't calculate
it because these [__] all right
talking about my parents these mothers
let's just bleep out the curse words I
refuse to let him curse about his
parents carry on Thief
mother
so you have to you have to you have to
blurt I'm a Child of God carry on Oh no
you're not get the [__] out Hey listen
[__] out of here anyways they never talk
about what they have right they never
talk about their problem their issues we
know
issues and problems okay
long after so peep game so I get to and
I know you I know what you're thinking
because everybody's like yo how could
you not put this together this dude
never really spoke about he's like you
know he was always down playing what he
had so whenever I was talking I was like
no it's just it's nothing it's really
just a little something uh they just
doing this thing just to
it's just um it's preventative it's just
it's not the nurse so I'm I'm trusting
the nurse saying no it's just it's
nothing it's not a big thing cancer is a
big thing well I mean I would have heard
chemo would have just said cancer I
understand but if he's telling me it's
preventive it's nothing big you don't
he's like down playing and like the way
they made it feel it was like if it was
no sometimes they use chemo for other
[__] okay okay gotcha it's nothing big
it's not what you think it is okay it's
you know nothing big but you know I'm
kind of scared because it's in the brain
that's all he said and I was like yo you
could have said I
straight up I have that so yeah it's
it's yeah that's my little side cut all
right all right well there you go break
the Noose
so she used to go wants to say honey I'm
getting older and I actually want an
actual relationship I just feel we have
great chemistry in the bed and we are
comfortable and get alongside the ice
game we're ever going to do stuff
together or is this all it's going to be
he said this is just it for now why did
you meet someone I said why just for now
no I didn't meet anyone if you want I'd
tell you if I met someone else I'm not
the type to just jump into a
relationship he said
I'm not really looking for anything more
than that right now I said why you look
like you looked for that in the past why
not with me him I'm busy at work and
then we didn't talk for two days and I
made my profile picture an ugly cartoon
who looks like an ex he completely
deleted his social media he hasn't
answered my text asking
my text asking see Drew an ugly cartoon
that looks like his ex and put her on
her profile pic that's weird
read that back was I wrong or Petty did
I communicate bad and then he says he
completed completely deleted his social
media or he hasn't answered my text
asking why he blocked me I know he
deleted it was I wrong or Petty did I
communicate bad does it sound like you
just didn't want a relationship with me
why not reply that's weird the the
picture with the X being super weird yo
that caught me our garden everything was
fine until she said that
you understand what I'm saying
oh yeah
and her name username is acceptable cat
this [__] is crazy yes okay good
yeah you're crazy
okay I mean this one's not even
complicated he's just you're crazy no he
just doesn't like you that much no and
you're crazy you know
you didn't have the attribute for a
girlfriend for him uh and but you kept
pushing he said no probably didn't want
to lie to you or whatever whatnot but
you going through the picture [__] yeah
you get blocked listen listen you're a
jump off you're only going there to give
him a BJ you're a jump off
that's what it is I'm too busy at work
no he just doesn't not interested in you
he wasn't too busy at work with the
other women he dated She's Not That Into
You yeah I ain't more complicated than
that that's it
eight years him blocking you honestly is
probably good for you yeah gonna help
you move on faster yeah so you can stop
being disillusioned about it yes because
you probably wouldn't want a
relationship with him at any point
during those eight years and this whole
time he's just like come over and blow
me you were basically something he
masturbated into
if he never goes out with you anywhere
seen in public going to do stuff with
you at any point in time
uh he's just
a jump off masturbating into your holes
it's not sex
you're like a commercial
wow
and it's okay
you're allowed to be that and not
everybody got inspired to bigger things
in life sometimes you can have low
points that's what you want that's what
you did or that's what you tolerated
whatever uh but hopefully this is like a
growing point for you and then the next
Dynamic you won't accept just going over
to some dude's house on a regular basis
to blow
I don't know too many guys here who
would love to go to a gross place just
to eat them out and walk away it might
be sexy one time but if you're
constantly doing that I'ma look at you
like you're a loser
this
no more than that here you get your
earphone
um
that's all that was you just didn't know
it like for eight years honey like
that means you're 26. y'all started when
you were 18 you didn't have no
relationships or any kind of real dating
experiences during that whole time it
sounds like
you might be a bit socially [__] too
when it comes to dating that's what it
sounds like to me the questions you're
asking are so obvious
literally everybody in the comments is
like honey he told you what it was so I
don't know
the picture thing
something that was so crazy
and want to have want to communicate
after that
I mean there's nothing to communicate I
think that's what I'm saying I think her
doing that picture thing is actually
amazing it's a great thing
because it made him gave him a reason to
cut it off because yeah but after that
she wants to communicate like you do
something that crazy people are going to
want to don't have to communicate
especially if you nothing but [__] it's
a blessing in disguise his thing a lot
of people can't handle hookup culture
it's just not before most people
especially ladies it's just not
okay I know some people want to say it
is there's some people who can't well
most of them can't and they go into it
thinking it's what they want in reality
like in terms of long-term goals it's
just not it it actually works against
them because think about it she wasted
all those eight years doing that [__]
with him expecting you know only to
realize like oh she does want more she
always wanted more and she's now salty
that other women got a chance and why
didn't she just like well you didn't set
yourself up for that future and I'm not
here to admonish people if you want to
be in hookup culture go and be a hookup
culture but be honest yourself about
what it is that you actually want a lot
of people are accepting situations that
are lesser than what you really want
just because it's something well guess
what something isn't always better than
nothing okay
Believe It or Not sometimes it's better
to have nothing because at least you're
starting off with a clean slate you're
up you're open right having a shitty job
that occupies 80 hours of your day okay
not always the best idea if you want to
build a career towards something or you
need to get skill sets for the next line
of employment like you have no dating
experience now you're coming off your
friends with benefits where you're
pretty much one-sided and treated
terribly
buy your own choice
it's like you're 26 and stunted in a lot
of ways
you didn't invest any of that to suffer
from a daily perspective so like oh to
me it's just one of those things where a
lot of people need to stop accepting
these kind of Dynamics if they really
don't want them I think people are
learning that they're getting better at
voicing that voice which is great but
you know I don't wish it on her and I
hope she recovers from this and gets
yeah definitely but a lot of people are
really not good at voicing that
and then they're like well how can he
just voice what you wanted you stayed in
a situation and didn't really actually
want
and then after that when the thing
doesn't work anymore you're like well I
wanted more well if you wanted more you
shouldn't stay there true absolutely
that's how I feel about it too anything
else you want to say no all right well
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below you want to hear from